[Music]
dude this is
crazy this kid that got arrested the 17
year old oh yeah for hacking twitter
yeah i don't really want to talk [ __ ]
about him because he like he has friends
and like clearly they have capabilities
so you know let me just say
what he did was very bold
yeah i mean i just crazy that he was 17.
yeah that part is actually wild and hold
on let me i mean
i mean it's crazy because the they're
trying him i think they're going to try
him
on the basis that he could have had like
worldwide lasting
economical effects happened because of
this attack oh you know my god
so either work for the nsa or go to
prison for [ __ ]
30 years yeah i mean i guess
cause he really could have changed the
world you know he had [ __ ] obama's
twitter account
that is so wild dude i mean elon musk's
he could have made the
markets tank for a day he could have
lost people billions of dollars
and it's very true i mean bro he is he
looks like
man man he looks evil man
yeah there's a little smurf just dude
i would not [ __ ] with this kid
wild bro 17 years old how do you even
get into hacking when you're set like
how do you what disc order what discords
are you in you know
i mean i want to see the hacker discords
you play minecraft long enough dude
you meet some people yeah yeah dude bro
i've been
i played playing counter strike i meant
like some [ __ ] i told i told this
story this dude [ __ ]
uh call them like green or like green
69.
we were uh we were playing some scrim
and these
these dudes were talking [ __ ] to him
he's like all right watch this and he
[ __ ] like hacked their server and he
like took it away from them
he like changed like their admin
password and he was like in their irc
channel being like [ __ ] you
like you want your server back kiss my
ass
like how do you even get into it though
i do
well so what's the first forum you land
on just by accident and you're like well
this seems kind of cool
and then how do you what 17 years old
how do you know that much about like
machine code and like
that part is crazy i i know at least in
uh
back in the day there was a forum called
mygot myg0t
and they were like uh they they
i would imagine that's how you get into
it as a kid because i i assume that's
still a thing like hackers make like
like clans or like groups on games
and like i would imag maybe not but i'd
imagine that's that's how like they kind
of tout the ability to hack the game and
the game is irrelevant to them because
they [ __ ]
they can do whatever they want yeah um
all right i remember we played a game
and this dude came in with a my god tag
and we were like ah no way dude
um he was playing with us and then he
changed his name from the my god thing
we're like oh
are you in he's like nah nah it's a joke
and then on irc
you could used to be able to check if
people were idling channels
okay he he was uh he was what they call
opt like he was
given like admin access in in the mygot
channel
and we were like yo what the [ __ ] this
dude is a my god i remember we were like
freaking the [ __ ] out
that we were like just like this [ __ ]
hacker hacker and he could have just
hacked your your guys [ __ ]
i mean maybe he could have just been
like a 30 year old dude with like a
script and like
like we didn't know his proficiency but
yeah but i'm just saying i say all that
to say i feel like that's how
maybe now you would get into it as a kid
like you're
14 and you're playing with some dudes
who are older than you they're like yeah
bro like you want a [ __ ] hack it's
like
some weird gang [ __ ] yeah yeah dude we
got to jump you in on minecraft
you got to build a [ __ ] beautiful ass
city minimum 20 thousand hours and we
gotta
[ __ ] it up he's like no
sorry man that's the price and if you
don't cry during the whole thing
you're in
[Laughter]
or another just like what's your what's
your favorite minecraft thing that
you've built oh man i built the death
star dude i love it so much we're going
to [ __ ]
bonsai buddy plays yeah i love the death
star
i built the test store i love the death
star
we're going to fight zuckerberg what's
your favorite thing you've built
i built this really cool interconnected
network
with with uh communication abilities and
yeah cool bro it's gonna disappear
tonight
if you want to join join the hacker
squad
yo look that [ __ ] up dude there's like
this well-known [ __ ] animation of a
kid like
downloading scripts from my god and then
it just ends up like frying his computer
oh no i'll play like the first
10 seconds of it yeah uh
maybe we should also finish with a um a
fibonacci
oh
sorry bro maybe we should finish with a
with a fibonacci number
dog this [ __ ] was like on new grounds
look at let me let me screen share this
[ __ ]
maybe today compooning of noobs
bro this is like straight up flash
animation [ __ ]
um bonsai
watch stream yeah watch stream there we
go oh you're streaming to me
oh my god i love the map dust
i've been pulling so many noobs on it
maybe today i'll prune enough
noobs that can raise my rank in the
server
from three to one
what the [ __ ] is this this is like
guys let's move out so i'm just like
i'ma just talk it over but it's
basically like a flash animation
just recreating like you know some kid
playing counter-strike he's like super
proud of his accomplishments in just
like a single
server okay and so this is him like
setting up to camp
you know and then uh
he's gonna get clapped real quick
and so the story is that he gets so
pissed that he gets clapped that he uh
uh he goes to the my god forums and he
downloads
hacks and then he just ends up frying
his computer oh no
so this is him again
[Laughter]
yeah this is like some deep cut [ __ ]
that is some deep cut [ __ ]
yeah it's like i don't even i'm
pretending like i get this but
nah this is like some weird cult
animation shade after 13 years this
thing only has 256
000 views wow that's a deep cut right
deep cut bro yeah aged myself but
anyway
you